[Music]
so you know ufc this weekend how was it
shout out to ufc man thanks thanks for
the invite tfti so do they set you up
they give you tickets and they give you
like a cool seat and
yeah interview you and
and now you just have that connect you
can just do that anytime they just kind
of hit me up and they're like you want
to pull up dude
sounds sick man
[Laughter]
toss me that connect one time
well you know i feel like uh you know i
don't even feel like i'm you know i'm
always in there like do i
is this like does everyone know that i'm
here um you know like is this a trick
so
you know i definitely go there and i act
like yeah i'm supposed to be here
but that definitely doesn't feel that
way
because it's i mean
man i have to say
these dudes behind me
so
clearly there is like
we do this [ __ ] too when you watch
sports there's a certain element of you
that's like this is what you should have
did right yeah i think everyone
experiences that right
fighting i think is like the highest
degree of that
and these dudes behind me were so funny
because they had a lot of expert
opinions that night
but they were all doing uh they're all
betting
and then this group of friends was
betting with each other
so they had placed bets like
with the sports book yeah and then now
they're doing different bets with each
other okay
like they're hedging right so like at
the sports book they would bet for one
guy then with each other they bet the
opposite okay so they were betting
against each other
amongst each other so is this drunk like
this like six six like drunk kind of
chunky dude
loud as [ __ ] yeah and his boys are next
to me they're [ __ ] traditional
meatheads at least one of them that
dude's shirt was so tight
he looked like he looked like
trader joe's salmon like that's how
thick like you know just stuck to him
this shirt was
and then his other boy is is like uh
dude's got a mullet but like a stylized
mullet you know shave sides like kind of
mohawk situation and
it's important that you get the
descriptors of all these dudes so you
can understand the vibe so the six six
chunky dude
would be like hey
the odds are 201 on this guy you want to
go
and then meathead and uh mohawk
we'll go
well i don't know do you want you want
to split this one yeah [ __ ] it man let's
do it and mind you how old do you think
these guys are
um
25
35 40. yeah okay
okay yeah hell yeah
uh would you imagine any of these dudes
having gray hair
no yeah yeah okay yeah yes they do hey
so is that vibe yeah they're kind of
like the guys that we were talking about
last week at the monster trucks
yeah yeah but this is like um them
if they got
ds in geometry instead of f's okay
so
you know a lot a lot of riveting
conversation like one of them was like
how old's that waitress
she's like 22 or some [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yeah that's chill
that's sick
you know man the older i get he says oh
no not you know
while being you know 35 with peppered
hair and a [ __ ] mohawk
sticker i look yeah
you know the older i get me in the real
life the more i realize like i will not
put up with the [ __ ] oh no
like as soon as a girl just starts doing
the [ __ ] i [ __ ] i don't i don't
stand for that like what matt says
have a kidney when he just goes dude i'm
just we're like how are you doing man
he's like you're just sick of all the
[ __ ]
like he says it as a joke oh yeah those
type of dudes are actually about that
yeah yeah sick of all the [ __ ] man
like dude
what's happening in russia and ukraine
right now
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you ask me i'm sick
of it if i was putin like i would not
stand for that [ __ ]
what
take russia that's what they're saying
yeah yeah they're just dumb as hell
if i was putin like i straight up would
not stand for that [ __ ] yeah yeah
i would not put up with the [ __ ] is
a [ __ ] alpha yeah that's why the
whole world hates him dude yeah what's
that misunderstood what's sad is this is
probably a talking point on some like
yeah men's podcast yeah exactly yeah
putin's actually a sigma male and here's
why
[Laughter]
everyone's jealous of putin anyway he
marches to the beat of his own drum you
know yeah
he's apparently he's actually five six
or something oh really we can get into
wartime propaganda okay yeah all right
anyway so you know old boy is like i do
not put up with the [ __ ] hell yeah
and i'm immediately laughing like
are you 40 like yeah yeah
yeah like when she hits me up for child
support payments i'm like i do not put
up with them not pay those things that's
[ __ ]
i just want to be like this because like
your back hurts now like you can't walk
yeah like you're hearing you lost it a
little bit like you don't have the
faculties to put up with the [ __ ]
you're just old like you physically
can't i'd like to
yeah
like you're not 20 you can't entertain
the [ __ ] because you don't have all
your five senses still like your [ __ ] is
deteriorating yeah of course you can't
your brain is slower yeah
so after you know they
get to talking about
you know this 22 year old waitress then
they get back to the betting and they'd
be like
ah yeah man [ __ ] it
you know and then they get to roasting
each other and um
the six six chunky dude had a funny one
he was like
you know what the sports books say when
they see you in that shirt
we're talking about sam in here okay
he's like they say you can bet anything
you want all night because calling him
you know [ __ ] mark he's calling him
an idiot okay like the sports book like
looks at him in his salmon t-shirt uh
yeah this guy's an idiot okay i like
that yeah it's a good little bit yeah so
anyway so
they start
it starts off
and they're taking bets and then they
start critiquing the fighters you know
this guy [ __ ] sucks yeah he's been on
his back like all [ __ ] night
dude blows
saying crazy [ __ ] like
i'll i'll give the context of this fight
after but one guy's losing they're like
yo after this fight this dude's wife
should be smacking him in his busted eye
every day
to remind him how shitty of a fighter he
is what
psycho stuff jesus christ just it makes
no sense oh my god yeah when this guy
gets home from risking his life
for
minimum wage for his family so they can
eat
his wife better beat the [ __ ] out of him
i hope his wife gives him a bunch of
[ __ ] when he gets home i would never
put up with that that's why i hit my
wife yeah
that's not funny
stop laughing
it's not funny that's [ __ ] up you you
know all right anyway
i bet
she better give him a bunch of [ __ ]
i wish he said that dude yeah
so whatever so they're saying all this
crazy stuff they did have one
winning line for me which like they
broke me with this one so the
the two the the co-main was two
brazilians
it was like rafael dos hanos and uh
let's do moycano
um
and these dudes were so dumb
they couldn't figure out
like who was who or anyone's nationality
okay the chunky guy he was asian but he
kept saying the wildest most racist [ __ ]
ever
to the point that his own like you know
i don't put up with the [ __ ] like
this they started mocking him they're
like
meg can you believe it
6 6 korean dude
screaming usa
then that guy is like hey [ __ ] i
immigrated here by choice this is the
greatest country on earth go [ __ ]
yourself
they said nothing
they just like
wait wait wait i don't i don't get what
happened who was who was yelling so the
six six chunky guy yeah he was korean
he's korean okay and he was yelling usa
he'd be on crazy racist stuff just like
about the fighters okay
but it all was like kind of motivated a
certain way okay it's definitely pro usa
comments okay until it got to another
fighter and he was just saying other
dumb [ __ ] but basically he was just
being a lot okay
so to the point that his friends are
kind of like
man look at this yeah
66 korean guy just screaming usa okay
and then he does that whole like go [ __ ]
yourself okay i see this boy just like
[Laughter]
it was like daddy hit some kid at the
table
and everyone around us like got quiet
after he said that it was just so like
uncomfortable
so anyway so
rafael's fighting mikano
they can't figure out which brazilian is
which
and then one of them's like uh i think
dos anjos is mexican
i mean
it's a you know it's a fair dumb person
observation but i'm just like all right
yeah so then the best part to me though
is like they would keep critiquing the
fighters and then they keep taking more
bets and i'd be laughing listening to
who they're gonna pick i'm like oh
they're gonna lose again well they're
gonna lose and they chose all the losers
okay you know hell yeah
and so it was just really funny to me
like listening to them with all this
expert commentary and then pick their
next bet and just knowing like i would
just sit there kind of watching the
fight but really i'm like
i can't wait because as the fights would
go on you could hear their morality just
dropping more and more and then the the
korean dude would rub it in their face
he'd be like you want to buy out i'll
let you buy me out for 300 right now
let's go colby clothing town yeah
literally and then they're like no no we
got one more round dude
then by the end of the night they're
like
dude we're not doing too hot here
yeah
every fighter we've picked what is this
like six rounds on our back the whole
night jesus [ __ ]
and real quick because i know someone's
gonna call out that i chose jorge
in my little ufc cut did you yeah i i
was like you know i gotta go street
jesus
and
i
i hate to put it this way but
you know
i didn't have strong conviction that
jorge was going to win but i had hope
yeah you know right i was like i was
like maybe right maybe he'll pull it off
yeah he almost did yeah he almost did
yeah why didn't this is just me
critiquing yeah athletes yeah because
you don't put up with the [ __ ] why
didn't he attack him
he was when he got him wobbly like that
he was gasps wasn't he so gassed man oh
man he could have just pounced on him i
feel like it would have been over jorge
has not looked that slow to me in a long
time if i was in the ring that's what i
would have done yeah yeah
in fact mozzarella you're an idiot
i'm calling you out right now
no i'm kidding it was a it was a fun
fight to watch well sort of i don't know
i he got arrested i don't really like
the ground and pound
it wasn't even a lot of pound yeah it
was just ground yeah
okay like the ground stuff yeah everyone
jokes about
or everyone makes comments about cole i
should say jokes everyone comments that
colby is like
accurate but he just doesn't have a ton
of power
you know it's like he he would hit jorge
with like some good combos but jorge is
just standing there yeah
he could take it
um
but yeah i did
i've not seen him look that slow in
person
and then it's a weird thing because
watching them live is cool but i still
find that like you're kind of still
looking up at the moment yeah yeah did
you bet on it
no you just said in the video you were
like i gotta go yeah you know i gotta
you